10 candidatos compiten para suceder al
presidente actual de filipinas rodrigo
duterte que deja un legado cuestionado
principalmente por su violenta lucha
contra el narcotráfico según los sondeos
de opinión el candidato a la presidencia
ferdinand marcos júnior hijo del ex
dictador ferdinand marcos que gobernó el
país durante 21 años imponiendo un
régimen autoritario y su binomio sara
duterte hija del actual presidente
acumula en el 57 por ciento de los
apoyos este binomio que propone instalar
una corriente populista conservadora
cerró su campaña en medio de una marea
roja y verde desde manila
arme el dueto marcos tutearte trabajamos
para acercarnos a nuestros compatriotas
y pedirles su apoyo para permitirnos
reunir a todos los profesionales que
podamos para empezar con la unificación
del pueblo filipino
no muy lejos del evento de marcos y
duterte en makati un distrito acomodado
de manila lenny robredo se hunde en las
encuestas con un apoyo del 25 por ciento
y actual vicepresidenta aunado el voto
progresista su discurso se ha centrado
en temas de derechos humanos feministas
y temas de la comunidad lgtb y jamming
mara minsal a matt damon las muchas
gracias a todos por acompañarme en la
lucha por nuestro país desde el
principio ya hemos despertado esta lucha
no es sólo de un candidato
yo sólo soy un vehículo de amor que
abarca todos los filipinos
esta campaña se ha visto envuelta por la
denuncia de noticias falsas en redes y
ataques continuos entre los candidatos
son 65 millones de filipinos los
elegibles para votar y el país también
elegir a otras autoridades como
congresistas gobernadores y alcaldes